♪ ♪
>> Chris: IF YOU OWN STOCK AT
AMAZON, YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT TOO
HAPPY WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP THESE
DAYS.
THE PRESIDENT'S CONTINUED
CRITICISM OF THE ONLINE RETAIL
GIANT HAS BROUGHT TO STOCK
PRICES DOWN AND SPARKED TALK OF
A POSSIBLE LAWSUIT.
TONIGHT, CORRESPONDENT
DOUG McKELWAY LOOKS AT THE
PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS AND THE
PUBLIC'S REACTIONS.
>> AT LEAST 17 TIMES,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TWEETED HIS
DISPLEASURE AT AMAZON, CITING
HIS ALLEGED ABUSE OF THE TAX
SYSTEM, THE POSTAL SERVICE, AND
OTHER RETAILERS.
>> YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
SMALL TOWNS THAT HAD TO
BEAUTIFUL MAIN STREET WITH
STORES, THE STORES ARE ALL GONE.
>> AMAZON OWNER JEFF BEZOS HAS
REMAINED SILENT.
LOBBYING FOR AMAZON DID "POST"
EDITOR RESPOND, TELLING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT JEFF
BEZOS HAD NEVER SUGGESTED A
STORY TO ANYBODY HERE.
HE'S NEVER CREATED A STORY,
NEVER SUPPRESSED A STORY.
A LARGER QUESTION, IS A LEGAL
AND ECONOMIC ETHICAL BOUNDARIES
OF SUCH PRESIDENTIAL PRIVATE
SECTOR BADGERING.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS
WITHIN HIS POWER.
ETHICALLY, THE PRESIDENT HAS AN
OBLIGATION NOT TO INTERVENE AND
COMMERCE BECAUSE OF THE
RAMIFICATIONS IT CAN HAVE WITH
SOME OF THE STOCK MARKET.
>> AMAZON LOST $53 BILLION LAST
WEEK AFTER REPORTS THE PRESIDENT
WAS OBSESSED WITH REGULATING IT.
CONFLICT OF INTEREST
CONSIDERATIONS WERE ALSO RAISED
IT TODAY.
AMAZON IS A BIDDER FOR A NEW
PENTAGON CLOUD COMPUTING
CONTRACT.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS NOT INVOLVED
IN THE PROCESS.
DOD RUNS THE COMPETITIVE BIDDING
PROCESS.
>> RADIO TALK SHOW HOST, MARK
LEVIN, A FREQUENT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, TOLD HIS LISTENERS
OF THE PRESIDENT IS WRONG ON
THIS ONE.
>> I CAN IMAGINE WHERE YOU WOULD
BE IF THIS MIND-SET HAD SETTLED
BEFORE THE INDUSTRIAL
REVOLUTION.
WHAT IS THIS OIL STUFF?
I'M IN THE HORSE AND BUGGY
BUSINESS.
THAT'S NOT FAIR, PUTTING PEOPLE
OUT OF BUSINESS.
WHAT ARE THESE CARS?
>> OTHER PRESIDENTS ARE NOT
IMMUNE FROM PLAYING
PRIVATE-SECTOR FAVORITES, AS
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA TARGETED
STAPLES.
>> WHEN I HEAR LARGE
CORPORATIONS THAT MAKE BILLIONS